[Music]
a florida jogger can you be the jogger
you're the jogger where did jogger use
his martial arts
to fight off an 18 year old boy what who
tried to strangle him
and lock him in his closet
to fulfill sexual fantasies
no i'm doing it i'm doing it
in the closet but then i he i need this
fantasy fulfilled so i open the closet
door i come in unlocked i stopped i
stopped you from doing it though yeah
wait okay who was trying to do it yeah
all right
there's a jogger in florida he takes the
same route every uh i guess like every
day and there's an 18 year old boy
that's been watching him from his house
and this 18 year old boy was having
these like jeffrey dahmer type thoughts
and starts planning how he's going to
kidnap this guy and make him like a sex
slave in his closet i don't know why he
admitted to all that but basically he
went over and tried to choke him with a
belt for like a rope so he just comes up
behind him the jogger says he's running
with his earpods on and then just feels
a rope around his neck this kid is
trying to drag him over how did he even
catch him when he's running
for an 18 year old he didn't right when
this happened the jogger turns around
and does martial arts which kind do you
think it was yeah it was like this
he grabbed my neck and i went
and i broke three and i ran away so if
you're getting grab like grab his neck
from behind what a belt grab his neck
from behind and then what's the thing to
get out of that this is basically what
he did i'm 18.
all i do i reach and try to tie my shoe
and he flips over my body
for real you don't get choked to death
yeah no it looks like a porno watchman
that works that's just how it goes you
go or do you go
backwards yeah yeah i would go backwards
too you know you're like because when
he's choking you you go oh and then
you're choking yourself and you go ah
backwards oh [ __ ]
and the second time still got me off
guard
there's two there's three there's a
bunch of things wrong with an
eight-year-old person yeah you you guys
trying now you gotta learn
what's your scenario
he's having sexual fantasies about some
dude right
unless he has like a thing of
a petite dude no like it's a jogging man
that's a big dude like damn i really
want some of that action
now you now you're gonna go tackles like
i don't like i want some of that lion
right there the lion's gonna eat you
that's the wrong guy david and goliath
sex like looking at a small thing he's
like i'm having sexual fantasies about a
petite guy
i'm guessing this 18 year old is
probably like the chance of this fool
knowing martial arts must be slim yeah
right because he's not the smallest
other thing is my dude's running so he's
already his adrenaline level he's pumped
already right he's on a runner's head
now you come in here hide and try to do
a sneak move on someone in action he's
already warmed up yeah he's already
[ __ ] warmed up
he's fatigued
forgot one big point this guy is a
regular jogger who works on his fitness
his cardio is through the roof that's
what i'm saying he is a police person
that trains already he's trained right
vo2
yeah just jacking off at the balcony
he's doing too quick the best he should
have tripped him yeah if he would have
tripped my dude is that what you would
do chloroform idiot this guy's a [ __ ]
dude let's teach him how to get a guy
you could put a bunch of like elmer's
glue all over the floor so you get like
stuck when he runs yeah yeah but how's
he gonna get him there but he's gotta
stay there for a while but my dude is
18. obviously he doesn't own the house
how's he even gonna get a sex slave into
his mother's house
keep him there like what is going on hey
why is he going straight to sex lady
yeah so was he gonna choke him take him
out and drag his body into the house how
strong do you think he is and you're
you're going to like this plan he covers
his driveway in bed sheets and he brings
that belt with him and he brings a can
of axe deodorant to mace the guy what
gets that far in the plan you know eight
serials are getting dumber huh but the
weird thing is it failed at that point
like he didn't get further than the
choke he's on bed she got [ __ ] i bet
she's over him he's rambo like in the
[ __ ] yeah he's like doing like that
rambo thing hiding in the bedsheets yeah
i just painted my dude from hunger games
is like painting himself into the rock
yeah
he's like an amazing makeup artist just
to do this
wait you said so this jogger knows
martial arts yeah is it just a fighter
doing his road work
and he just picked on the worst guy ever
oh yeah you just go you know
on a boxer yeah he picked on [ __ ]
carlo doing his five miles daily five
miles he's trying to lean [ __ ] doing his
[ __ ] daily runs well the weirdest
thing is that that i find weird is that
that's where it ended right he tries to
choke him gets away calls the cops cops
arrest the kid but the kid all that
other details was just given
he just said he just said it out loud
like he didn't have to tell him all that
but and those sheets this is what it was
for yeah so he told the cops
he told the cops that he he's
complaining that he was unlucky because
the jogger was stronger than him this
kid's 18 he's 5 10 200 pounds oh daddy's
a big kid he's a big 18 year old boy i
know but he was attracted to a very
athletic physique what do you think of
that face guys
wow
looks droopy on the left side
he looks like he's uh he couldn't handle
it he looks horny that he didn't get to
come
the runner but there is a picture of the
axe body spray and i guess it was apollo
said wow oh cool apollo is good for
macing yeah that has the most blinding
properties have you guys seen that one
video it's like a surveillance camera
there's this chick
she's like on the phone like waiting at
a bus stop and then a guy pulls up next
to her with the backpack
and it just looks like two people
waiting for like the bus stop like looks
super normal
and then out of nowhere this guy just
takes out his belt and just chokes her
and she's trying to like choke him to
death and good thing like another like
uh person that was just walking came and
separated him and tried to like tackle
him and then the cops came or whatever
and i'm like man this is crazy just
random acts of violence just happens
we're just living in the purge now yeah
it's like what the [ __ ] the scariest
thing is that dude was being watched for
weeks by this kid yeah can you imagine
doing a routine and somebody's been
watching is there anybody watching y'all
is there anybody watching you have
routines that's why i switch up my
running i don't know if i'm being
watched but i'll be watching a few
people i'm trying to check them off my
list yep when i go to the gym i don't
use the same squat rack i go one
door
i'm like oh [ __ ]
why is that guy at his own gym he's like
i'm gonna go squat right now just
kidding i'm gonna bench press
he wanted a sex life yeah that's a crazy
thing because that's very similar to i
think if i remember correctly jeffrey
dahmer had this similar thing when he
was watching a jogger and eventually
caught him he probably watched the same
thing did he just try to kill them or
did he said he said he learned that from
a movie but he wouldn't say which one
it's probably the movie dahmer so my
little brother dion is in the movie i
remember that yeah he's one of them he's
getting raped and stuff oh [ __ ]
oh dion yeah
but see again dion's
a smaller guy
so the bigger dude come and get the
smaller guys it's gonna be easier and
doesn't to do a sex scene on the fab
bros no oh he doesn't see so he that was
his redemption yeah he has his
redemption we got a second shot
i've been waiting a long time that was a
really good sex scene
that was one of the best sex scenes ever
i want to see this movie joe's in it
there's
it's very hot
you didn't want a sex scene
not his
joe got a gun joe got a gun oh you got a
gun i had a i had a [ __ ] scene i had a
[ __ ] something about your character at
all i got a posse
i could tell you what he is
so he is uh um he's like a low-level
gangster that
runs a chicken fighting ring like a
rooster [ __ ] fighting you made this role
for joe then that is a based on shoe
story this is joe's life joe brought
dimensions to the character we would we
did not have plans
it was so fun
it was so fun dude it was so joe's just
being a joke just being jokes did you
have did you have to read for that like
they did no i was frustrated no you knew
i was right for the role
who could do this he was like joe could
do this let's call joe thank you was his
name joe in the movie because that would
be great his name was uh obama what was
his name
jimmy jimmy uh not for god
i actually named him after my character
i did in uh
in in hawaii if i have a little game i
named that character after that gangster
character
didn't i even get my i brought my own
outfit too right oh the suit that's your
suit yeah yeah i did my whole character
i did my whole wardrobe and then i even
showed you pictures i'm like this how i
picture the dude made the other crew
dress like him
wow that's yeah much i loved it dude he
killed it he killed you guys
i can't wait to watch it um last night
um i was in the hot tub
and then um the dog was just [ __ ]
barking like crazy right and then like
lately we've been having um people
stealing cattle uh converters off of the
[ __ ] street yeah that's happening
good money doing that bro so like man i
was like man he's barking way more than
usual right and it's like it's an odd
hour it's like 10 o'clock
so i went out and then i went to the
gate and i peeked out and i was like
damn what's going on because he keeps
barking i can't see what's happening
right and i opened it and i went out to
the street
mind you i'm in my underwear
steaming from the [ __ ] [ __ ] hot
hot [ __ ] steam because it's cold as
[ __ ] but my body's hot and i just ran
out i'm barefooted and everything and
i'm just like wait you're underwear not
trunks underwear yeah cause then
i mean i just put off my clothes i just
took off my clothes and i went inside
you lucky these weren't underwear yeah i
was wearing underwear
and i was like thinking
i'm here to catch the bad guy
but the neighbors if they saw me right
now i'm the bad guy i'm a bad guy yeah
and i kind of walked in with shame like
okay i probably didn't need to come out
all the way into the street or whatever
it was just like
and you're sleeping i'm steaming bro you
might look like uh like like an asian
terminator
just drops down all you need is like a
red contact yeah dude but then if he's
but if he's not naked then you know he
didn't time travel yeah
you got to be fully committed but i also
thought it was pretty stupid because i i
went under i went out there unarmed i
went out there without anything but at
the same time i didn't realize how
wait if i was a thief and a man that was
steaming that was naked came out
i would be scared it's a scary scene and
i was like you know what i should do is
if i do see someone i should pull down
my underwear and chase them and then
take a [ __ ] that usually works no and
then grab them and kiss their ear and
say i'm a i'm a lover not a crazy no i
want to deal with crazy you know what
i'm saying yeah no one wants to deal
with crazy no one deal crazy if i grab
the bad guy right pinned him to the
ground butt ass naked
and it whispered in his ear i'm a lover
not a fighter be careful
and then be careful that's my strategy
honestly if i ever get in a fight like
that i would
my god brother's like real though back
when we got he's crazy he passed away
since now but he he was crazy back then
we you know we live in a neighborhood
and we you know you always get hit by
gangsters like where you from where are
you from like and you're like we have
mcdonald's and these
those are just his like where you from
and he looked at him he was like
from the moon
he said wake up from the moon for real
and there was just like
you ain't [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
but what if this dude
different level now yeah
that happens too we claimed we're like
hey we ain't from here we from up north
el norte no dog we're from san francisco
everything you say is a gang exactly
horrible
but i think you can whip some ass naked
what if you just whip someone's ass
naked that might be nice oh that would
be kind of that would be a viral video
already just off someone's ring cam
steaming man
[ __ ] something gotta look converted
stealing jail plotting your death like
this [ __ ] beat me up naked i
gotta go kill this dude
[Music]
you